Memorial Day weekend is The Unofficial
start of summer and that also means tick
season is fully underway the number of
tick disease cases has jumped 25 percent
from 2011 to 2019 according to the most
recent CDC data the most common is Lyme
disease but Health experts are also
closely watching a rare disease that is
spreading in the Northeast it is
becoming a bigger concern something to
watch out for here CBS News medical
contributor Dr Celine Gander joins us
now she is also editor at large for
public health at kff Dr gounder thank
you so much for joining us this morning
great to be here so let's talk about
this why are we seeing an increase
already in these tick-borne diseases so
we've seen this big increase over the
last decade and it's linked to climate
change so as you have warming of the
temperatures shorter wind Winters longer
spring summer fall when the ticks are
active you're going to see more
transmission you have more parts of the
country that are also hospitable to a
text and then you have other issues like
deforestation
Suburban ex-urbance neighborhoods being
built in areas that used to be very
heavily wooded where you have a lot of
ticks and so the exposure is just
getting greater yeah this is something
we're worried about we spend a lot of
time Outdoors we're always finding them
at this point How concerned are you
about this new illness this rare
tick-borne illness that's rising in the
Northeast right now I think you're
referring to babesiosis which is another
tick-borne disease has many of the same
symptoms as Lyme disease but in severe
cases can cause kidney failure lung
failure very low platelet counts we have
seen this on the rise you know as part
of all of the tick diseases being on the
rise and it is concerning
what can you do to protect yourself
well start by wearing long sleeves long
pants light clothing is better because
you can spot the ticks on yourself I
like colored clothing all right got it
things like insect repellents with DEET
there's a chemical called Permethrin
which is a pesticide we also use it
actually to treat lice or scabies
treating your clothing your hiking gear
with Permethrin can be helpful here to
reduce your exposure so in the kind of
the cost benefit analysis between
getting Lyme disease versus putting all
the chemicals on your body to prevent
the ticks from getting on you you think
put the stuff on you
I would say given that yeah cost benefit
for sure okay sure oftentimes Dr ganders
you know you're out in the woods and
multiple ticks might land on you you
don't know it until you get home and you
check yourself how soon can you be
infected with Lyme disease or this other
uh disease once a tick gets its pincers
into you yeah it takes about 36 to 4
divorce for transmission to occur so if
you go out hiking walking your dog
whatever it is you come home at the end
of the day and you check yourself you
remove any ticks you're still in that
window of you know within 24 hours where
you can reduce really prevent your risk
of acquiring one of these tick-borne
illnesses and what about pet owners and
Nancy I know you got to talk about your
Instagram yeah like how do I have pets
too for both humans and pets yeah so
there are tick preventatives that you
can give your dog or a cat you should
talk to your vet about that to see
what's appropriate and then when you
come home at the end of the day from
walking your dog check your pets for
ticks all over it can be a little harder
to spot because of the fur sure but if
you do find a tick on yourself on your
person how do you get rid of it is it as
easy as just pulling it off you have to
be careful here use tweezers and you
want to get the entire body of the tick
you don't want it to break up as you
pull it off don't use things like heat
some people will try to burn it off or
use Vaseline that's not a good idea that
can actually increase the risk of
infection the mouth can can be left
behind if yeah careful and then it just
keeps their like nibbling this is
Nightmare and you can get it yeah yeah
exactly so you really want to break it
off or pull it off I should say all all
whole together and should you be
concerned if you see one that's engorged
I mean oftentimes if you haven't caught
one you don't see it it it's filled with
blood exactly well if it's in gorgeous
it means it's probably been there for
longer and in that situation or if you
just think the tick may have been there
for more than a day and a half or two
days I would contact your doctor to see
do you need to get a dose of Doxycycline
or some other antibiotic
just wear long sleeve clothing lovely to
see you spray off those games oh my gosh
don't do what they're doing
you got one on your leg right now